what's on the video bah you fine you
[ __ ] Tim rock you find this guy bye
you cow you Newt cow this is adam from
PlayStation grenade and I have been
forced kicking and screaming to play
Resident Evil's tease at the beginning
our [ __ ] right but cutters let's do
this it's good it's okay it's a false
alarm just a plastic baby all right
let's go tickle the ivories down let me
feel much better yeah you come down calm
down something you get him Tony a game
sunshine what's on the video ah you fine
you [ __ ] Tim rocky find this guy give
me a brave I hey don't put your bell end
the don't like ladders I don't like
letters what a phantom no I didn't see
ya I didn't see nice ok I don't want to
play anymore it's like right where we're
going dude where is he what's around
there [ __ ] believable back ghost
right come here all right I'm a month I
mean mom cuz I love see another cost
there's so many girls why is it always
becoming a lot at first I don't like
ladders and really do like ladders right
okay we're okay there's nothing here is
a wall there's a white thing we are
comply
no oh he didn't see me you just keep
pinging against that wall of and I'll
stand there and wait you coming down
because I don't do this on my own are
you [ __ ] right pretend we're at home
it's cleaner than my house to be honest
let's get a Pepsi Max out of the fridge
well the beverages are available of
course I've got the key just got to get
out the house just to the front door and
out easy easy there's nothing to worry
about just what oh my did you see that
did you see the size of that burger it
was like a foot tall oh god oh god
crouch crouch what's for the music
what's with the eerie sounds I'm not
good with sound design please stop it
did it he's the door just put the key in
and get outside simple as that easy
let's do this what the [ __ ] welcome to
the family oh you sure I I'm not taken
from behind it not in a good way so
shall we test out the physics engine
whoa domestic violence will not be
tolerated we buy you cow you'll nude cow
so many mannequins in this house right
just peg it just get out just run run
run run run run run get out while you're
gone right Oh max I have a weapon seem
take me out now I can [ __ ] [ __ ] up now
come on take that ball take that covered
take that picture frame yeah I'm the
boss right I'm going upstairs oh god I
don't like upstairs I do not like
upstairs but I'll stare at the wall yeah
you look away nice buns by the way you
have to do something with those
mannequins what the they've turned round
they have turned round Oh cheese cheese
hard rock out no messing with her don't
even leave a scar oh sorry breast shot
didn't mean that I'm really sorry all
right I can't take anymore my nerves are
absolutely shot so this was me Adam
reporting for playstation grenade
playing the resident evil 7 demo or the
opening our there's so much more to look
forward as though you are
I'm not going to swear anymore no more
swearing right it's been a pleasure
hopefully I'll see you again
you